mes chers collègues
nous allons pouvoir commencer cette
audition nous avons l'honneur
d'accueillir aujourd'hui Madame Agnès de
la transition énergétique à qui je
souhaite la bienvenue à la ministre
votre présence parmi nous malgré les
contraintes d'un agenda débordant à
teste de votre engagement sans faille
sur la sobriété énergétique ce sujet
souvent noyé dans un flot de malentendu
assurgi au grand jour ces derniers mois
l'annonce faite au coeur de l'été
dernier concernant la préparation d'un
ambitieux plan de sobriété a d'abord été
accueilli il faut le dire par une vague
de scepticisme
cependant en ce qui concerne notre
approvisionnement électrique forcée de
reconnaître que notre nation a réussi à
naviguer habilement dans les eaux
tumultueuses de l'hiver évitant ainsi
les coupures et les délaissages vous
avez ainsi prouvé de manière indéniable
que la sobriété peut être une arme
puissante et efficace pour atteindre les
objectifs de réduction de consommation
et reprendre le contrôle de notre destin
énergétique le temps de cette audition
étant limité par la prochaine séance
publique des questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement au Sénat je passe
immédiatement la parole à nos collègues
Olga givernais et Stéphane pinoir qui
sont rapporteurs de l'étude de l'Office
que l'Office a engagé sur la sobriété
énergétique je suis certain qu'il
tâcheront de ne faire qu'un bref propos
introductif pour rappeler le cadre de
cette audition
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre comme l'a dit le président en
rien nous sommes effectivement très
honorés de pouvoir vous accueillir
aujourd'hui au Sénat pour cette audition
publique centrée sur le sujet de la
sobriété énergétique alors cette édition
s'inscrit dans le cadre des travaux que
nous menons avec ma collègue Olga
givernais depuis l'automne dernier au
nom de l'Office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques sur ces îles de la
commission Développement durable et de
l'Aménagement du Territoire de
l'Assemblée nationale sur je mets des
guillemets les implications en matière
de recherche et d'innovation
technologique de l'objectif de sobriété
énergétique
donc nous sommes attachés dans ce cadre
avec Olga givernais a accomplir cette
mission et nous avons entendu d'ores et
déjà plus d'une cinquantaine d'acteurs
notamment du monde industriel des
startups de la recherche de l'Université
des milieux associatifs et plus
globalement de toutes structure qui
réfléchit de près ou de loin à cette
notion de sobriété qui est parfois au
contour un peu flou le gouvernement a
mené lui aussi dans ce domaine une
action résolue concrétisée par la
présentation le 6 octobre dernier du
plan de sobriété énergétique à l'issue
d'une phase de concertation avec là
aussi différents acteurs économiques des
représentants du monde associatif des
énergéticiens des experts ainsi que des
élus
il s'agissait avant tout de faire face
effectivement dans l'urgence à cette
crise énergétique européenne provoquer
en particulier par l'agression russe en
Ukraine et aggravée dans notre pays par
la découverte de ce phénomène inattendu
de corrosion sous contrainte de nos
réacteurs un certain nombre de nos
réacteurs nucléaires qui nous étaient
amenés à arrêter à un certain nombre de
réacteurs c'est problème de corrosion
ont d'ailleurs donné lieu à une audition
publique de lopex au Sénat le 27 octobre
dernier
tout récemment le gouvernement a annoncé
une nouvelle phase de son plan de
sobriété énergétique et que vous aurez
l'occasion très certainement d'évoquer
dans votre propos
à l'examen par ailleurs à l'examen de la
future loi de programmation de l'énergie
et du climat probablement à l'automne
prochain les délais sont pas tout à fait
calés mais cela devrait donner lieu au
parlementaire de l'occasion
parlementaire de débattre sur ce sujet
de la sobriété énergétique et surtout
au-delà du débat d'envisager les voix
des moyens d'y parvenir
en effet à côté de cette transition vers
les énergies décarbonées qu'elles soient
renouvelables ou nucléaire et de
l'efficacité énergétique est un autre
pan d'action qui permet de limiter la
consommation énergétique par un service
pour un service rendu identique la
sobriété énergétique apparaît de plus en
plus comme un troisième pilier
indispensable à la réussite de la
transition et à la teinte de nos
objectifs qui sont ambitieux en matière
de climat
il ne s'agit plus uniquement de faire
face à une situation d'urgence comme
cela a été le cas après les différents
chocs pétroliers des années 70 mais
d'une prise en compte de la sobriété sur
le long terme pour en assurer la
réussite avant de passer la parole à
Olga hivernais je rappelle que c'est
audition est filmée diffusée en direct
et qu'elle sera ensuite disponible sur
le site du Sénat
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
monsieur le Président nous sommes
honorés de vous entendre aujourd'hui sur
ce sujet fondamental pour la transition
énergétique française et la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique je veux bien
sûr parler de la sobriété qui nous
rassemble aujourd'hui ce n'est ni la
décroissance ni l'écologie punitive la
sobriété de toute évidence un pilier
essentiel de notre stratégie pour sortir
des énergies fossiles et faire des
économies d'énergie comme le président
de la République la souligné lors de son
discours de Belfort pourtant ce constat
n'allait pas de soi il y a quelques mois
lorsque le gouvernement a présenté son
plan de sobriété énergétique comme la
présenter Stéphane piénoir ce premier
plan visa à éviter les pénuries de gaz
et les coupures d'électricité il a fallu
réduire volontairement tous les postes
de consommation chauffage éclairage
déplacement utilisation du numérique
l'objectif était de réduire notre
consommation d'énergie de 10% d'ici à
2024 vous allez avoir l'occasion madame
la ministre de nous faire un le retour
d'expérience sur ce sujet malgré les
nombreuses critiques formulées à
l'époque les injusgeants se plant
superflu les autres au contraire
insuffisants tous les scénarios de
prospection en font ainsi un levier
fondamental pour atteindre la neutralité
carbone il faut trouver ces leviers et
également lever les freins plusieurs
études récentes publiées par l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie l'ADEME et
RTE et encore tout récemment
transpratégie montre en effet qu'elles
permettra de limiter la pression sur
notamment les métaux critiques
nécessaires à la production de panneaux
solaires ou de batterie la sobriété sera
tout aussi indispensable pour bénéficier
pleinement de l'amélioration de
l'efficacité énergétique parce qu'elle
permet aussi d'éviter les effets rebonds
qui se produit lorsqu’un d'efficacité
dans l'utilisation d'une ressource
entraîne une augmentation de la
consommation de celle-ci il est donc
essentiel que la sobriété énergétique
puisse avoir toute sa place dans les
débats sur la stratégie énergétique et
climatique française en particulier à
l'occasion de l'examen de la future loi
de programmation énergie climat à cet
égard je suis particulièrement honoré de
pouvoir en être pilote du groupe de
travail le temps de cette audition est
en limitée je souhaite maintenant
conclure et je sais que nous aurons
quelques questions ensuite à la suite de
votre intervention je vous remercie
merci beaucoup Madame et Monsieur les
rapporteurs chers Olga Giverny cherche
Stéphane piénoir mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs et députés membres de
l'OPEX je vous remercie de
l'organisation de cette édition qui est
consacrée à la sobriété énergétique moi
je porte la sobriété énergétique mais on
pourrait élargir le propos et Madame la
Députée vient de le faire à l'instant
qui est un des quatre piliers
effectivement de la politique
énergétique que je porte la sobriété qui
repose sur le changement de comportement
et non sur le pari technologique
c'est probablement le levier le plus
rapide et le moins coûteux en termes de
mise en oeuvre pour engager la
transition énergétique mais car elle
repose sur les comportements sur la
culture d'une certaine manière aussi la
sobriété pose d'autres questions que
l'efficacité énergétique que
l'accélération du déploiement des
énergies renouvelables ou la relance du
nucléaire l'enjeu est donc de savoir
comment nous pouvons inciter à cette
évolution des modes de consommation
des entreprises des collectivités et des
individus
toutefois et avant de vous exposer notre
stratégie notre action en la matière je
veux remettre en perspective
notre action pour la sobriété dans le
contexte climatique et énergétique dans
laquelle elle s'inscrit
vous l'avez constaté l'année 2022 a été
une année de bascule au niveau
énergétique la guerre en Ukraine a mis à
jour de manière très visible et mordante
la dépendance de notre pays et de notre
continent aux énergies fossiles au
niveau climatique je crois qu'il n'est
pas besoin de recenser les épisodes de
canicule de sécheresse de mégafeux et
tous les éléments visibles sur notre
territoire à relier à
au dérèglement climatique c'est dans ce
contexte que j'ai pris la décision à
l'été 2022 d'élaborer un plan de
sobriété énergétique un plan qui était
certes conçu pour faciliter le passage
de l'hiver mais un plan qui de manière
assumée ne se limitait pas à cela
puisqu'il constitue la première marche
vers notre objectif de réduction de 40%
de notre consommation d'énergie finale
d'ici 2050 conformément scénario porté
par les experts de RTE alors c'est 40 à
50%, si nous souhaitons atteindre la
neutralité carbone d'ici là
réduire notre consommation énergétique
ne se décrète pas et je pense que les
travaux que vous avez menés depuis le
début de votre mission voulons confirmez
c'est pourquoi j'ai souhaité que le plan
de sobriété initie d'abord pour les
grands acteurs une mobilisation générale
ce plan de sobriété les fonder sur trois
principes et sur une méthode
les trois principes sont les suivants
d'abord l'état doit être exemplaire car
comment les acteurs économiques les
collectivités locales les Français
pourraient constantir à faire évoluer
leur comportement si l'État ne faisait
pas lui-même sa propre révolution
deuxième principe nous demandons en
priorité aux grands acteurs les grandes
collectivités locales les grandes
entreprises
les grandes administrations de faire les
plus gros efforts de réduction de
consommation cela participe de cet
élément d'exemplarité c'est une question
de justice et d'acceptabilité si nous
voulons que les Français s'engagent à
leur tour sur le chemin de la sobriété
énergétique et puis ça a une qualité
assez profonde c'est que c'est efficace
c'est-à-dire qu'on parle des acteurs qui
gèrent le plus ou qui suscite le plus
grand nombre de déplacements sur le
territoire à l'occasion des déplacements
domicile travail au sein des activités
que nous portons chacun et puis c'est
nous qui gérons le plus grand nombre de
mètres carrés finalement
de manière resserrée le troisième
principe c'est qu'il s'agit de partir du
terrain et de la réalité des
usages c'est une approche qui fait
résolument le choix de l'incitation de
la responsabilisation de la transparence
aussi plutôt que celui d'une coercition
qui serait finalement indéterminée on
prend une loi elle s'applique à tout le
monde et on fait on croise les doigts
pour qu'elles soient adaptée à tout le
monde or nous le savons toutes et tous
la loi est le seul ne suffit pas à
fortiori sur des enjeux de comportement
et de culture le meilleur exemple de
cela est l'obligation du 19 degrés de
chauffage de la température de consigne
dont je rappelle qu'elle figure dans
notre arsenal réglementaire législative
depuis
1978 sans pourtant être appliqué après
plusieurs mois la méthode ensuite pardon
c'est celle d'une co-construction autour
de 10 groupes de travail sectoriels qui
réunissent plus de 300 fédérations
professionnelles des experts des
associations environnementales et des
élus locaux cette méthode elle permet de
couvrir les principaux enjeux de la
sobriété pour l'administration pour les
collectivités locales pour le secteur du
bâtiment du sport de la culture du
commerce des grandes entreprises et
après plusieurs mois de concertation
j'ai pu présenter le 6 octobre 2022 aux
côtés de la première ministre un plan de
sobriété avec l'objectif de baisser de
10% notre consommation énergétique d'ici
fin 2024 alors effectivement accueilli
avec beaucoup de circons circonspection
dans la manière dont elle était
positionnée et avec le niveau d'objectif
outre les nombreux engagements
volontaires des différents secteurs le
plan a conduit à l'adoption de plusieurs
mesures réglementaires nécessaires
notamment pour faire la chasse au
gaspillage énergétique et surtout pour
permettre aux acteurs d'être sur le même
niveau d'engagement il est important
lorsqu'il y a des risques qu'il y ait
des acteurs qui ne jouent pas du tout le
jeu et que ce soit au détriment des
acteurs qui jouent le jeu d'avoir ces
définitions de règles communes
lorsqu'elles sont réalisables et
parfaitement je dirais
incorporé par les acteurs je pense
notamment au décret en posant la
fermeture des portes des locaux
climatisés ou chauffés afin d'éviter la
déperdition énergétique et a été publiée
le 5 octobre dernier le décret imposant
l'extinction nocturne des publicités
lumineuses publiées également le 5
octobre le décret permettant
l'extinction des publicités lumineuses
en cas de pic de consommation
d'électricité c'est à dire en cas de
signal échovoit rouge publié le 18
octobre le décret imposant des systèmes
de pilotage technique des bâtiments type
PACS et le décret permettant la
suspension temporaire de l'obligation
pour l'eau chaude sanitaire dans les
bâtiments tertiaires publiés le mois
dernier nous avons également mis en
place des mesures de soutien pour
accompagner les acteurs et les Français
dans leur effort de sobriété alors il
est vrai que la sobriété ne suppose pas
théoriquement des investissements c'est
là où la frontière est parfois un peu
grise avec l'efficacité énergétique mais
des accompagnements en matière
d'ingénierie de construction de
programme sont utiles nous avons
accompagné les collectivités locales et
en lançant le programme Actiplus doté
220 millions d'euros qui permet de
réaliser des diagnostics sur l'éclairage
ou sur la gestion des piscines dans les
collectivités locales pour les TPE PME
nous avons lancé avec CCI France et
c'est ma France et la poste le programme
best et what doté de 26 millions d'euros
pour accompagner les particuliers nous
avons revalorisé certains certificats
d'économie d'énergie pour mieux soutenir
le changement de mode de chauffage au fi
ou le fait de mieux piloter le chauffage
chez soi nous avons également lancé un
plan covoiturage et un plan vélo
également assorti de certificat
d'économie d'énergie pour inciter ceux
qui le peuvent à passer à des mobilités
plus durables et nous avons accentué le
soutien la rénovation énergétique sur
les aspects les plus rapides
au travers du dispositif la prime rénov
donc on reste dans quelque chose qui ne
peut pas s'apparenter à de la réelle
efficacité énergétique même si encore
une fois la frontière est tout à fait
pour eux grâce à ces mesures grâce à la
communication gouvernementale aussi
puisque nous avons porté une campagne de
communication à destination du grand
public dont les résultats en termes de
pénétration du grand public ont été très
très exceptionnelle partout en France
des efforts ont été faits pour baisser
le chauffage limiter les éclairages
revoir les habitudes de transport et de
consommation
et je vous livre les résultats notre
consommation d'électricité globale ABC
de 8% et notre consommation de gaz de
16% évidemment après correction des
effets météo sinon ce serait pas un
chiffre très intéressant au total nous
avons baissé notre consommation combinée
de gaz et d'électricité de près de 12%
sur l'hiver dernier c'est absolument
massif et nous n'avons pas trace de
trajectoire équivalente dans les 50
dernières années nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre ont baissé de 8,5% en
quatrième trimestre
et vous vous souvenez quels étaient
grosso modo et Tales sur les trois
premiers trimestres dans un contexte de
crise climatique où nous avons
effectivement eu recours à peu plus de
gaz
et je trouve ce chiffre très intéressant
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
ont baissé de 15% dans le secteur des
bâtiments sur toute l'année
si réacteur nucléaires alors un peu plus
puissant donc ça se compare pas
exactement mais c'est pour dire que
c'est vraiment pas rien cette réacteur
nucléaire en somme nous avons su faire
en trois mois ce que notre pays n'avait
pas su faire en 30 ans
de citer quelques exemples relatifs à
l'application du plan de sobriété les
consignes de température ont été très
largement respectées dans les logements
et dans le tertiaire c'est la principale
mesure qui a permis cette baisse
drastique des consommations des sondages
montrent par exemple que 92% des
collectivités territoriales ont baissé
la température de chauffage
76% réduit la période de chauffe 86% des
gestionnaires d'infrastructures
sportives ont diminué la température de
chauffage des efforts importants ont
également été faits sur l'éclairage pour
les bâtiments publics les éclairages
ornementaux sont désormais sauf
exception particulière et éteint entre
22h et 6h du matin des premiers efforts
ont été engagés pour limiter la
consommation de carburant pour
promouvoir le télétravail
afin de montrer l'exemple et dans
mesurer l'utilité j'ai même mené au sein
de mon ministre de mon ministère pardon
une expérimentation sur le télétravail
le but était de mesurer la baisse de la
consommation des bâtiments lorsqu'ils
sont totalement mis à l'arrêt sur des
week-ends
[Musique]
l'effet potentiellement rebond chez les
agents publics avec accepté de nous
communiquer leur donner de consommation
de façon à avoir une mesure globale de
l'impact sur les économies d'énergie les
premiers résultats sont très positifs
c'est une étude qui a été menée par
l'ifpeb et l'ADEME et qui nous donne
aussi des renseignements puisque nous
avons fermé des bâtiments sur Paris en
banlieue parisienne en province avec
différentes situations par rapport au
réseau de transport en commun ce qui
nous apprend
je dirais des bonnes pratiques si on
veut qu'effectivement le télétravail
puisse être un levier de baisse de la
consommation d'énergie
grâce à ce plan nous avons donc engagé
notre pays sur cette trajectoire de
baisse de la consommation et nous avons
je pense aussi contribué à inscrire le
terme sobriété comme étant quelque chose
de naturel et d'acceptable dans une
politique de transition énergétique et
écologique et j'ajoute écologique
puisque mon collègue
Christophe Béchu a mis en place de son
côté à un plan sobriété sur l'eau et que
nous voyons que nous allons
effectivement avoir besoin de différents
usages de la sobriété sur les matières
premières sur les intrants consommés sur
le foncier c'est au fond l'approche du
zan qui avait précédé
ses réflexions donc tout cela est relié
une baisse cruciale a cours comme un
long terme si nous voulons atteindre nos
objectifs climatiques cela nous est
montré encore cette semaine par le
rapport de la mission Jean Pisani féerie
sur les incidences économiques de
l'action pour le climat qui énonce que
d'ici 2030 la transformation
reposera principalement sur la
substitution de capital aux énergies
fossiles la sobriété contribuera à la
réduction des émissions et effectivement
il chiffre un potentiel
15% tout état de cause moins de 20% et
je crois que notre objectif c'est à
minima de livrer ses 15% et peut-être
d'aller taquiner les 20% voire plus d'où
l'intérêt aussi de nous mobiliser
d'avoir l'approche la plus scientifique
et expérimentale et possible pour pour
avancer
il précise d'ailleurs que ce rapport la
sobriété n'est pas nécessairement
synonyme de décroissance et peut de plus
être source de bien-être j'y reviendrai
nous devons donc pérenniser approfondir
les mesures de sobriété pour les
inscrire dans le temps c'est pourquoi
lors du conseil de planification
écologique en janvier 2023 le président
de la République a annoncé la
préparation d'un deuxième plan de
sobriété
ce plan je l'ai engagé des mars et je
m'appuie à nouveau sur une large
concertation avec les collectivités
territoriales les corps intermédiaires
les experts les acteurs économiques les
associations environnementales les
administrations nous avons réuni plus
une ou plusieurs fois ces différents
groupes de travail sectoriels et nous
avons continué à réduire notre
consommation énergétique depuis le début
de l'année donc ça c'est le point
positif c'est qu'on continue à voir en
gaz et en électricité la trace de cette
baisse de consommation d'énergie je
précise qu'on le voit y compris chez des
consommateurs qui ne sont pas soumis à
la volatilité des prix ceux qui sont
protégés par le bouclier énergétique
en revanche de frustration
sur lequel nous allons travailler plus
avant le numérique reste encore un angle
mort de notre politique de sobriété
parce qu'au fond c'est une boîte noire
c'est-à-dire il est beaucoup plus facile
de se dire la lumière est allumée il
faut l'éteindre que d'avoir une notion
des consommations numériques en tant que
je dirais consommateur direct mais
également dans les grandes organisations
d'avoir une idée de ce que représente la
conception de nouvelles applications ou
de nouveaux ERP dans leur consommation
énergétique deuxième frustration c'est
celle de la baisse de notre consommation
de carburant qui pour le coup n'a pas
été au rendez-vous il faut le
reconnaître probablement parce que
l'attention sur le passage de l'hiver a
aidé sur les leviers l'électricité et du
gaz mais a été moins présente sur celui
du carburant or ça doit être un élément
que nous devons aborder et renforcer
la profondissement de l'application des
grands acteurs notamment les grandes
entreprises à qui j'ai demandé de
prendre des objectifs chiffrés de baisse
de leur consommation de les adopter en
conseil d'administration et de les
présenter en ce si c'est possible
puisque ça leur donne une plus grande
force juridique de les publier sur
Internet ce qui les rend opposables
d'une certaine façon au moins d'un point
de vue réputationnel de développer le
télétravail et de regarder la
possibilité de faire de la question de
la vitesse sur des routes de leur ample
de leurs salariés un élément dialogue
social pour aller effectivement dans la
même direction que celle que ces données
l'État
à moyen terme et je crois que ce sera
l'objet de la loi de programmation
énergie climat et des attentes que nous
avons à l'égard du groupe sobriété la
question qui est posée elle suppose de
prendre un peu plus de hauteur et de
surplomb sur sur ces questions ça pose
finalement la question d'abord d'un
travail sur les co bénéfices de la
sobriété si on veut rendre la sobriété
desirables il faut se pencher sur quels
sont ses bénéfices sur la santé sur la
biodiversité sur un certain nombre
d'éléments qui sont activables et qui
peuvent rendre beaucoup plus acceptable
ces mesures de sobriété je donne deux
exemples
40% des trajets en ville sont des
trajets de moins de 5 km
premier élément deviennent un élément
les médecins s'inquiète du fait que nous
sommes nous ayons beaucoup moins
d'activités sportives et indiquent qu'il
faudrait une demi-heure d'activités
sportives légèrement soutenues par jour
et bien on pourrait lier l'utile et
l'agréable effectivement en faisant ce
lien entre abandonner la voiture pour
marcher ou prendre le vélo mais cela
suppose évidemment de créer une habitude
et une désirabilité pour ses
comportements et puis de créer aussi les
infrastructures parce que s'il s'agit de
mettre en danger son enfant quand on
accompagne à l'école avec son vélo je
pense que personne sera convertie
certainement pas moi
donc deuxième élément ou réflexion la
fermeture enfin l'éclairage public la
nuit nuit fortement à la biodiversité
c'est quelque chose de prouvé dans un
certain nombre de communes rurales ou en
périphérie cet élément se mesure mais
très rapidement
et très localement c'est à dire autant
il y a des enjeux de BIOS de diversité
qui sont planétaires et qui nous
préoccupent mais où notre levier
d'action
et se font dans un océan d'action que
nous devons mener collectivement une
manière coordonnée avec d'autres États
autant là on peut avoir un bénéfice
mesurable rapide et à proximité donc je
prends ces deux exemples qui sont je
dirais pas anecdotiques mais
illustratifs mais pour montrer que il y
a vraiment un travail à faire deuxième
travail à faire c'est sur
l'éco-conception des politiques
publiques au fond ce que nous devons
faire aujourd'hui c'est s'opposer à
chaque fois que nous avons des
questionnements sur
l'implantation d'une nouvelle école de
réfléchir à qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
en termes de transport en commun en
termes
d'application énergétique avant que de
choisir pour d'autres ou en tout cas de
ne pas prendre en compte cette dimension
là donc les co-consception des
politiques publiques c'est un sujet
national qui intéresse au premier chef
le législateur mais c'est aussi un sujet
local et qui sur lesquels nous devons
pouvoir équiper nos élus les
collectivités locales puis le troisième
sujet c'est la mise en place d'une
gouvernance locale qui est peut-être
adaptée dans les groupes de travail que
l'on a commencé à avoir sur la sobriété
un élu de France urbaine indiqué au fond
si je voulais penser la sobriété des
transports je pourrais avoir un intérêt
à essayer de voir comment on peut étaler
les horaires de démarrage des écoles
pour étaler la mise en la prise en
charge des transports en commun entre 8h
et 9h du matin pour avoir plus de
latitude et ne pas avoir un pic que je
ne sais pas organiser
c'est une question qui est très bonne
mais les loups locales me faisait valoir
que il n'avait pas la main sur
l'éducation nationale qui n'avait pas
nécessairement la main sur les horaires
de démarrage dans les usines d'un côté
et dans les
euh les bureaux et que ces sujets là
méritaient quand même d'être posés alors
je pose la question j'ai pas la réponse
puisque évidemment la réponse est très
complexe il suffit pas de dire on va
étaler de 8 heures à 9h et tout le monde
s'en trouvera bien puisque là encore on
est confronté à la granularité du réel
et ce qui est compliqué dans cette
politique de sobriété c'est justement
d'affronter cette granularité du réel
mais à minima ça pose la question de la
gouvernance locale de la
contractualisation des acteurs qu'on
doit mettre autour de la table et là on
rentre dans une planification de la
sobriété ou en tout cas une un travail
plus en profondeur qui ira effectivement
beaucoup plus loin que le seul question
de à quelle heure on ferme la lumière et
à quelle température on fixe le
chauffage collectif alors mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et les députés
vous l'aurez compris après le sprint du
premier plan de sobriété nous nous
engageons avant dans un marathon un
marathon qui est crucial pour faire face
aux défis climatiques et donc je me
tiens à votre disposition pour répondre
à vos questions
bien merci madame la ministre nous
allons passer à présent donc un échange
avec l'ensemble des membres de l'office
je remercie chers collègues de faire
preuve de concision dans vos
formulations et je laisse la parole à
nos deux rapporteurs pour les premières
questions
merci beaucoup merci Madame la Ministre
effectivement vous avez évoqué un
certain nombre de points que nous avons
pu relever lors de lors de nos auditions
et vous avez raison sur l'organisation
la coordination de de nos systèmes
d'avoir de l'information c'est quelque
chose qui est important puisque lorsque
nous avons des plateformes numériques
qui peuvent nous aider à la décision qui
peut nous aider à la coordination sur du
covoiturage par exemple ou sur le
réglage de la ventilation dans nos
bâtiments c'est important ça fait ça
fait penser à l'éco-conception ne nous a
parlé aussi beaucoup de l'eau tech donc
c'est de l'innovation pour savoir
comment on construit nos équipements nos
infrastructures qu'on utilise l'énergie
grise qui permet de les fabriquer au
mieux et d'éviter de gaspiller avec
derrière une gestion du cycle de vie de
ces équipements pour être dans le dans
l'optimisation vous avez parlé de cours
de moyens de long terme une question
aussi sur
le calendrier les horaires la
saisonnalité c'est des pointes qui
peuvent toucher notre agriculture
lorsque nous voulons produire de manière
la plus la plus appropriée et enfin moi
j'ai une question particulièrement
l'énergie au prix de l'énergie baisse en
ce moment et tout d'un coup on voit
peut-être un relâchement en tout cas
c'est ce qui nous est remonté des
personnes qui voulaient évoluer faire
évoluer leur système et puis finalement
se disent ah bah non tiens maintenant le
gaz est revenu à un niveau abordable
donc on va mettre on va mettre en
suspens comment est-ce que vous pensez
qu'on peut aller plus loin pour
justement pour
inciter toujours toujours plus à trouver
ces leviers et ses solutions je rappelle
que la sobriété en France paraît assez
inédite par rapport à d'autres à
d'autres pays je crois que nous sommes
plutôt avancés et je salue vraiment
cette initiative du gouvernement d'être
force de proposition sur ce sujet merci
ok
alors plusieurs choses dans ce que dans
ce que vous dites d'abord effectivement
la notion de sobriété en France
manifestement semble un peu plus
spécifique c'est à dire là où beaucoup
de pays ont pris des mesures de passage
de l'hiver ils les ont clairement rangé
sous l'ombrelle passage de l'hiver et on
n'a pas forcément porter la même vision
qui consistait à dire non c'est une
brique incontournable de la transition
énergétique et d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce qu'il y a un deuxième
pays qui a cette approche là et on s'en
est aperçu je dirais presque un peu par
hasard mais en fait dans le courant des
discussions
de préparation de la commère ensuite du
G7 et du G20 volé énergie puisque l'Inde
porte un plan de sobriété et totalement
assumé comme étant un des éléments de
leur propre trajectoire de transition
énergétique l'Inde je le rappelle
président et
sera donc
organisera le G20
en Inde au mois de juillet et c'est dans
un des éléments que nous avons essayé de
glisser ensemble dans la déclaration du
G20
invité forcément
en tant que président du G20 pour
attirer l'attention sur l'importance de
la maîtrise de la consommation d'énergie
et qui est un sujet qui ne fait pas
aujourd'hui l'unanimité des pays du G7
et sur lequel autant le fait de baisser
la consommation d'énergie en utilisant
la technologie et relativement bien
assumée autant l'idée de s'interroger
sur nos modèles
de et sur nos habitudes et nos modèles
de consommation
paraît plus discutable en tout cas
fait l'objet de discussion au niveau
international et je pense que que c'est
un sujet sur lequel on va essayer de
pousser aussi les feux au plan européen
et on prend un intérêt national
s'agissant de l'effet prix il est
important et c'est un des sujets me
semble-t-il à regarder pour faire des
recommandations au niveau de de la lpk
pas nécessairement convocation et dans
la loi mais en termes de recommandations
de politiques publiques c'est évidemment
l'examen de tout ce qui est les niches
fiscales brunes d'un côté qui est un
exercice auquel vous vous livrez
quasiment chaque année désormais et qui
reviendra très probablement pour la PLF
2024 mais au-delà de ça c'est se poser
la question du signal prix et de la
manière dont on peut effectivement
sans enfin toujours cette ligne de crête
entre préservation du pouvoir d'achat de
ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens de sortir
des énergies fossiles facilement qui
sont aujourd'hui
assignés à résidence d'une certaine
manière au regard de ça qui pour aller
au travail et pour se chauffer non pas
les moyens de sortir de leur passoire
thermique ou de changer de véhicule ça
c'est un premier élément de politique
publique sur lequel nous nous devons
être au rendez-vous c'est les enjeux de
la rénovation thermique du leasing à 100
euros pour les voitures et des démarches
que nous développons pour densifier les
transports en commun et de l'autre côté
envoyer un signal prix qui est
effectivement d'un point de vue de
justice sociale et fiscal et de partage
de l'effort de la baisse de notre
consommation de notre consommation
d'énergie de notre trajectoire carbone
permet aussi de
faciliter d'inciter à des comportements
moins énergivores je pense que la
démarche que nous avons au niveau de
fitty-five notamment de faire en sorte
qu'aucun secteur aucun secteur n'échappe
à une prise en compte de son empreinte
carbone que ce soit le transport
international maritime que ce soit
l'aviation pour mettre les pieds dans le
plat ou que ce soit d'autres d'autres
secteurs qui aujourd'hui étaient pour
des raisons diverses de traiter
d'organisation sur les côtés aujourd'hui
ce que nous faisons avec le paquet
climat européen c'est effectivement
qu'aucun secteur n'échappe à ça après
est-ce que tous les secteurs payent le
prix réel de leur émission qui mérite
une revue rapprochée et comment on met
en place des trajectoires pour
finalement faire payer le prix du CO2 à
ceux qui en ont les moyens c'est
effectivement un débat qui je pense va
monter progressivement et qui est
présent dans tous les pays qui sont
confrontés à la question de la
transition énergétique
[Musique]
ce qui est quand même tout à fait
remarquable parce que on se disait
confinement arrêt des activités on a
baissé nos actifs nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre pile poil de 8% et à ce
moment-là c'est ce qu'on observe sur
l'hiver dernier alors quelques quelques
remarques sur sur vos propos d'abord sur
les co bénéfices je pense
qu'effectivement il y a beaucoup de
travail à faire pour l'acceptabilité on
sait que c'est un point extrêmement
important pour le passage à l'acte de de
l'opinion publique et rendre plus
pérenne aussi des choix des décisions
des usages qu'il ne soit pas juste one
shot comme on dit en mauvaise anglais en
tout cas juste pour lui pour passer
l'hiver avec les contraintes de prix qui
a évoqué ma collègue donc travailler
beaucoup sur l'acceptabilité sur
l'exemplarité de l'État moi on a
découvert un sujet
absolument crucial c'est la gestion
technique des bâtiments et j'ai plus le
chiffre en tête exactement mais on
s'aperçoit c'est une obligation légale
aussi et on s'aperçoit que la plupart
des bâtiments publics ne sont absolument
pas pilotés c'est à dire tout simplement
programmer le chauffage pouvoir que le
chauffage s'éteigne quand il y a plus
personne la nuit etc enfin des choses
que l'on fait nous naturellement dans
nos dans nos locaux privés ça nécessite
c'est dans la loi c'est absolument pas
appliquer donc là sur l'exemplarité de
l'État mais bien d'autres je pense qu'il
y a encore beaucoup de chemin à faire
ce qui nous a ce qui m'a frappé moi
c'est c'est les normes ou en tout cas
les indications qui sont données sur le
chauffage le 19 degrés
peut-être qu'il a été respecté il me
faut pas sans doute occulter l'effet
prix c'est à dire qu'il y a une
contrainte budgétaire dans le budget des
ménages qui se dit de toute façon enfin
moi j'ai comme tous on a eu des
témoignages de particuliers qui disaient
si je ne baisse pas ma consommation je
vais prendre un bouillon et je ne vais
pas pouvoir payer ma facture
d'électricité ou de chauffage c'est le
réflexe il a été celui-là et avant de
penser à des à la place de la France
leader international etc je pense que
c'était quand même le une question
budgétaire particulière donc faut quand
même pas
occulter cette aspect là des choses de
la même façon sur la vitesse
limitation de la vitesse qui est un qui
revient régulièrement dans le dans le
concert se limiter à 110 attention à
l'effet notre c'est pas un effet rebond
mais c'est un effet report sur des
routes départementales
voilà parce que entre un 80 ou 90 sur
une route départementale et incendie
autoroute peut-être qu'il peut y avoir
des des reports et par conséquent
l'effet en termes d'émission et sans
doute pas aussi aussi spectaculaire que
ça et je terminerai par quelque chose
qui je suppose en tout cas figurera dans
notre rapport que nous verrons
prochainement on est assez attaché au
terme juste assez la sobriété et assez
mal définie dans notre langue la
suffisance à une autre connotation qu'on
a du mal à accepter mais le juste assez
nous paraît c'est un terme assez
canadien qu'on pourrait qu'on pourra
retrouver dans notre rapport
merci beaucoup je pense que beaucoup de
choses ont été dites que je partage donc
je vais pas dire que je le partage plus
avant peut-être quelques éléments sur
l'exemplarité de l'État et sur la
nécessité de déployer une gestion
technique de bâtiments en plus c'est un
retour sur investissement qui est
très rapide en réalité donc ça c'est en
train d'être fait au niveau de l'État
mais il y a effectivement tout le levier
collectivité locale avec une
préoccupation sur aussi l'ingénierie
d'accompagnement des collectivités
locales alors c'est pas là on parle pas
de choses très compliquées par rapport à
des schémas de rénovation thermique
globale de bâtiments complexes des
collectivités locales mais néanmoins
c'est souvent un frein au passage à
l'acte d'avoir une notion de combien ça
coûte combien ça rapporte comment je le
finance et avec qui je fais le contrat
quoi pour être très dans le cadre
d'appel d'offres qui je demande et qui
me fera bien les travaux donc ça c'est
un point important nous nous allons
accentuer ces effets là deuxième élément
l'effet prix sur l'effet prix
plusieurs remarques entre le début et la
fin d'année c'est-à-dire sur des
contrats ou les résidentiels payent
exactement le même prix de l'électricité
ou du gaz puisqu'ils sont couverts par
le bouclier on a une amélioration entre
guillemets de l'économie d'énergie qui
est massive c'est à dire on est à moins
moins 2% en moyenne en début d'année on
est à -8 pour cent moins 9% en fin
d'année pour l'électricité et plus
encore pour le gaz alors il est possible
que la communication autour de l'envoler
des prix et eu un impact sur
l'anticipation du risque d'augmentation
de la facture et la présence à l'esprit
était certainement plus importante mais
je pense que c'est intéressant de se
dire que en tout cas c'était pas
peut-être l'effet prix était
psychologique mais si vous regardez les
consommations de janvier février et de
novembre décembre il y a une vraie
différence entre le début la fin d'année
pour des gens qui ont le même contrat
électricité gaz en revanche dans le
monde des entreprises et en particulier
dans le monde industriel l'effet prix il
est très net sur le gaz sur le gaz il
est très net sur l'électricité aussi
mais sur le gaz il est clairement
mordant puisqu'on voit une déviant enfin
une différence marquée entre les autres
et ce secteur là c'est-à-dire que eux
font moins 25 ou plus de -20% là où les
autres sont à -16 donc il y a vraiment
un écart qui qui marque l'effet prix
sur la question de la vitesse
effectivement d'abord éviter les effets
au port je le partage aussi ensuite la
démarche que nous avons
et qui en lien avec l'acceptabilité
c'est d'essayer de rentrer par des
leviers ou
on pose la question du changement
d'habitude dans des cadres qui sont
professionnels qui ont leurs règles du
jeu de négociation sociale qui ont des
préoccupations qui peuvent aller de
paires avec cette question de la
consommation de carburant de la baisse
de la consommation de carburant ça peut
être intéressant pour l'employeur
puisqu'il paye le carburant ça peut être
intéressant en terme de qualité de vie
au travail puisque c'est moins de
fatigue pour la personne qui conduit ça
peut être intéressant en termes de
sécurité au travail puisque à 110 km/h
un accident n'a pas tout à fait les
mêmes effets qu'à 130 km/h le l'effet
vitesse accentue très fortement les
impacts et c'est autant d'éléments qui
peuvent rentrer et puis c'est une
question de temps de travail puisque ça
allonge le temps passé dans le
déplacement et donc théoriquement c'est
un peu moins de temps passé
sur le lieu de la réunion qui est bon
mais est-ce que nous voulons créer en
fait c'est un questionnement au sein des
entreprises et au sein de chaque
employeur pour se dire quels sont les
meilleures façons d'économiser du
carburant en ayant une notion de qualité
de vie au travail de partage des
économies où vont les économies est-ce
que c'est pour faire d'autres
investissements est-ce que c'est pour
améliorer la rémunération des salariés
et on pense qu'il y a du grain en moudre
autour de cette négociation qui peut se
faire autour du télétravail de
l'organisation des réunions de
l'organisation des déplacements est-ce
qu'un déplacement dans une réunion est
justifiée à chaque fois ou est-ce qu'on
peut avoir une règle du jeu de vision
enfin en fait il y a beaucoup d'autres
choses qui doivent probablement être
dans la négociation sociale et je dirais
que ce qui compte le plus c'est que la
négociation se passe
et les leviers qui sont les plus adaptés
viendront ensuite dans la discussion ils
sont probablement différents d'une
entreprise qui est sur un territoire
ou la voiture est absolument
indispensable par rapport à des
entreprises enfin voilà je et moi je
revendique d'éviter d'imposer une vision
parisienne et centralisée de ce qui est
bon pour les entreprises et les
employeurs en revanche je pense qu'on
peut se poser la question de comment on
exige que la discussion se fasse et que
la négociation se fasse ce qui est pas
du même ordre
et voir comment on engage les employeurs
à avoir des trajectoires de réduction de
leur émission de leur empreinte en scope
1 Escom 2 aussi voilà troisième élément
c'est la valeur d'exemplarité
nous avons au niveau de l'État un
exemple qui sert un concours qui
s'appelle le concours cube et qui invite
les
une catégorie d'acteurs alors ça peut
être les écoles ça peut être les
bâtiments publics ça peut être les
entreprises à diminuer
leur consommation d'énergie et elle
s'inscrivent dans le concours il y a un
travail qui est fait au niveau des
salariés et lorsque c'est dans l'école
au niveau des professeurs des élèves du
personnel qui animent l'école il y a des
propositions qui sont faites et tout est
autour de la sobriété on n'a pas le
droit d'appeler un ami efficacité
thermique pour le faire ce qui est très
intéressant dans ces concours c'est
d'abord l'impact
en termes de baisse de la consommation
d'énergie on a une baisse de 11% de la
consommation d'énergie en moyenne et qui
va jusqu'à 30% pour les acteurs les plus
engagés et la deuxième chose qui est
très intéressante et c'est
particulièrement vrai dans les concours
qui ont été organisés en collège et en
lycée c'est l'impact que ça assure les
élèves qui répliquent ce qu'ils ont mis
en oeuvre au niveau de l'étape de leur
établissement à la maison et sur les
parents d'élèves si vous avez un taux
d'adhésion aux mesures qui ont été
co-construites au niveau de
l'établissement scolaire de plus de 80%
chez les parents d'élèves et chez et
chez les élèves et ce type de démarche
me paraît très intéressantes parce qu'au
fond et ça nous a aidée dans la
construction du plan sobriété en 1 elle
pose elle pose enfin elle montre que la
sobriété ça doit être aussi ça peut
aussi être un levier de narratif commun
et de projets communs au sein d'une
organisation et que c'est un
probablement beaucoup d'efficacité de
l'organiser comme tel
donc nous on va continuer à soutenir ces
concours en multipliant les les angles
comme type de catégorie les TPE les PME
etc mais je vous invite à vous pencher
sur cette démarche parce qu'elle est
assez
enfin elle est très intéressante dernier
point sur en lien avec la GTP c'est
comment utiliser finalement un certain
nombre d'outils où on est là aussi à la
limite de l'efficacité énergétique on
dispose d'énormément de données sur nos
consommations d'énergie aujourd'hui
enedis est reconnue comme le réseau
digital le meilleur au monde le meilleur
au monde et c'est des experts de
Singapour qui fait le classement donc on
peut pas les suspecter de bienveillance
particulière
nous serions en capacité de se poser la
question de d'avoir un certain nombre de
de
d'équipement qui consomment de l'énergie
qui pourrait être reliés par principe et
qui pourrait être soit faire l'objet
d'offre
de contrats d'électricité avec des
valorisation de la sobriété soit comme
on le fait pour les chauffe-eau
d'asservissement je rappelle que l'hiver
dernier le simple fait d'avoir déplacé
le moment où les chauffe-eau étaient
déclenchés automatiquement parce qu'il
se trouve qu'on a quelque chose d'assez
ancien qui est nos chauffe-eau sont
asservis et démarre sur un signal
électrique via le compteur dans un
certain nombre de cas c'est 2,5
gigawatts d'économie en puissance donc
si vous imaginez que tout ce qui est
chauffage éventuellement box etc vous
avez ce type de signal et que il y a
voilà une démarche du du ménage de dire
moi j'accepte ou je fais un optin ou
enfin il y a plusieurs possibilités pour
on a aussi des leviers dans ce domaine
là où on concilie le tech comme tu le
disais tout à l'heure et
sobriété efficacité énergétique
Alexandre
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la ministre pour votre exposé j'aimerais
revenir sur la question du rapporteur
qui a été fait sur
la baisse de la consommation
d'électricité et de gaz parce que j'ai
pas très bien saisi la réponse car on
l'a vu avec l'explosion des prix et
surtout quand on voit que la baisse de
consommation de gaz est 2 fois plus
importante en proportion assez
l'électricité on peut penser que c'est
les prix qui ont eu plus d'effets que
les recommandations gouvernementales
donc je voulais savoir qu'est-ce qui
vous fait dire exactement que cette
baisse est plus fait de votre
communication que de cette explosion des
prix et vous avez cité aussi également
le rapport de Monsieur Pisani Ferri qui
pour son plan
recommande des investissements entre 25
et 34 milliards d'euros d'ici 2030 et je
voulais avoir votre avis sur comment
vous comptez concrétiser ce plan si vous
souhaitez le faire et quels seront vos
priorités d'investissement je vous
remercie
alors sur la première question je le
redis très simplement d'abord le gaz est
beaucoup plus utilisé en proportion dans
notre mix énergétique pour le chauffage
par rapport à d'autres usages chez les
résidentiels que l'électricité je le
reformule c'est à dire qu'en gros
lorsque vous faites une température de
consigne vous avez une chance assez
certaine de toucher le gaz en revanche
vous utilisez assez peu de gaz pour
d'autres usages vous avez pas de
l'éclairage au gaz par exemple donc
voilà donc ça c'est le premier élément
et ça explique que le lien entre Besse
de la consommation du gaz dans les
acteurs chez les acteurs résidentiels
versus la baisse de la consommation
d'électricité j'ajoute un point
qui était sur l'effet prix donc je le
redis
pour les résidentiels le coût du gaz
comme le coup de l'électricité a été le
même du début à la fin d'année puisque
les prix le bouclier énergétique a été
constant du début à la fin d'année donc
pour monsieur et madame tout le monde
ils ont payé exactement le même prix du
mail
en février 2022 et en décembre 2022 or
en février 2022 les diminutions de
consommation étaient de l'ordre de 1 à
2% par mois en décembre 2022 c'est là où
on nous avons ces chiffres qui font un
combiné à moins 12% électricité et gaz
donc on peut dire que l'effet prix
sur les résidentiels
n'est pas l'élément d'explication
directe de la baisse de consommation
dès lors que la variable prix n'a pas
bougé entre le début la fin de l'année
merci président merci Madame à Miss pour
tous vos explications peut-être revenir
sur quelques points à travers de aussi
de deux trois remarques très concrètes
qui m'ont été y compris
manifester dans dans ce prescription une
première qui est tout simple j'en
profite de le dire moi je suis député du
Rhône et quand on est dans la région
lyonnaise on est toujours choqué y
compris maintenant de voir que donc
c'est très concret les halls des
concessionnaires étaient automobiles
sont encore à la moitié du temps à
éclairer est-ce que là dessus à un
moment donné il faut pas taper les
points sur la table le foot il va
prendre une mesure très claire très
nette donc sur ce sur ce point précis
deuxième sujet
moi j'ai discuté avec des une entreprise
une entreprise Lustucru qui se trouve
sur macoscription et ainsi aussi que sur
avec mes mes amis paysans qui conservent
des fruits et des légumes chez eux
on s'aperçoit que les consignes de
température donc notamment celles qui
sont réglementaires ne sont pas les
mêmes selon qu'on est à l'Italie par
exemple ou en France je pense une
certaine de choses presque
particulièrement concrètes et je me
faisais la réflexion à vous écoutant en
me disant est-ce que ce que vous avez
fait sur le nucléaire où vous avez
constitué une alliance donc de pays
européens autour du nucléaires est-ce
que sur ces questions sont propriétaires
vous avez l'intention d'essayer de
porter quelque chose donc qui soit à un
moment donné la possibilité d'avoir une
unité européenne et puis peut-être
bénéficier des retours d'expérience des
uns et des autres troisième point très
concret l'éco-conception l'écho
urbanisme et tous les coups conceptions
de bâtiments dans la vie d'avant j'étais
visposé à l'université et j'ai fait j'ai
eu le plaisir l'honneur de recevoir un
grand sportif français Stéphane Diagana
qui a fait qui travaille avec un certain
nombre d'architecte sur la conception
donc des bâtiments et notamment
vis-à-vis de la sobriété c'était il y a
une dizaine d'années en termes de
déplacement dans les bâtiments et on
s'est aperçu que dans pas mal de
bâtiments on en a un d'ailleurs comme ça
là
quand vous arrivez la première chose que
vous voyez ou presque dans les grands
bâtiment c'est l'accès aux ascenseurs
par contre si vous voulez prendre
l'escalier il un petit peu caché c'est
tout bête mais je peux vous dire qu'en
terme de CO bénéfice sur la santé là il
y a mon avis des choses à travailler et
je vous invite à aller au salon rue de
l'Université Nationale vous verrez le
problème
maintenant j'en viens à une autre
question par rapport à l'Europe il y en
a une autre vous avez fini tout à
l'heure à nous parlant de sprint et de
Marathon ça moi j'ai bien aimé l'image
et donc premier plan le sprint mais là
il faut s'inscrire sur un marathon or
pour faire du sprint il faut passer au
marathon c'est pas du tout le même
entraînement et
on a un côté là et peut-être on iron Man
mais je sais pas et du coup je me dis
quel retour d'expérience vous vous
faites donc de de de de ce sprint
justement et comment vous voyez la chose
pour construire un roman la suite
maintenant même si vous l'avez un petit
peu évoqué et notamment comment on
intègre comment on fait en sorte que on
soit pas sur quoi ça devienne la
sobriété d'un état mode de vie mode de
pensée mode de conception et comment on
intègre les questions sociologiques
notamment et est-ce que les sociologues
sont de la partie dans votre idée de la
suite de ce de ce sprint pour aller au
marathon est-ce qu'il faut pas avoir une
approche beaucoup plus en profondeur
dans la société donc voilà un petit peu
ma la réflexion qui me vient en vous
écoutant et merci pour tout ce que vous
portez sur ce sujet parce que je pense
que c'est particulièrement bénéfique en
effet pour notre pays
alors sur les halls les concessionnaires
automobiles je partage mes on retrouve
cette problématique dans un certain
nombre de circonstances c'est à dire que
il est un peu il est indispensable
d'avoir un décret qui donne sur ce type
de d'activité où il y a de la
concurrence une règle du jeu qui soit
commune parce qu'il faut pas que ceux
qui prennent sous leur chapeau de
aller dans un comportement qui est
désirable collectivement se retrouvent
finalement à être moins attractif du
point de vue de leurs clientèle que ceux
qui ne respectent pas ce type ce type de
d'enjeu donc après ça se joue à la fois
avec les filières c'est pour ça aussi
qu'on a travaillé par filière pourquoi
on a pris toute la grande distribution
ensemble parce qu'on s'est dit que ça
serait beaucoup plus efficace de les
avoir ensemble définir le niveau sonore
le niveau luminosité le niveau de
température et les règles du jeu de
ventilation dans leur magasin et que
s'il faisait tous la même chose on
aurait recréé en fait une nouvelle
vérité qui serait moins énergivore si en
revanche il y en a un qui fait quelque
chose et que les autres font
différemment on est sur
qu'à un moment ça on perd on perd de
l'attraction donc
de ce point de vue là il faut être
attentif effectivement lorsqu'on a une
des acteurs qui sont dans le même
registre à les prendre ensemble et aller
faire bouger ensemble et à
rendre le fait de ne pas bouger avec les
autres
potentiellement pénible soit d'un point
de vue
réputationnel ça peut être vu
d'attractivité de leurs salariés soit de
recrutement soit d'un point de vue de
questionnement de leur actionnaire soit
d'un point de vue tout simplement de
sanctions financières administrative etc
donc
c'est c'est là ce que nous envisageons
là ce que nous avons fait d'ailleurs
est-ce qu'il y a un plan européen autour
de la sobriété une unité européenne sur
le sujet c'est un sujet que je pousse
moi en tant que ministre j'ai parlé du
G20 et de la
rédaction que j'ai glissée incidament
dans le communiqué du G7 énergie et
effectivement on a des accroches
aujourd'hui dans les textes existants
qui sortent de enfin qui sont issus de
la crise ukrainienne un intérêt de la
Commission européenne mais pas encore
une politique très bien définie avec un
référent qui bat la mesure pour en faire
un élément incontournable évident on va
y travailler avec l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie puisque son
président fatihirol veut en faire un des
thèmes de sa ministérielle de janvier ou
février prochain donc c'est des sujets
qui commencent à percoler ou
effectivement la France est assez en
avant-garde sur la question de
l'éco-conception je parlais des
conceptions des politiques publiques
effectivement et qu'on conception des
bâtiments et c'est la question en
mauvais français du net c'est-à-dire que
comment on rend très facile et très
accessible la sobriété si les règles les
réglages par défaut de cet objet là
était en économie d'énergie et par
exemple vous déclenchez pas la vidéo
automatiquement lorsque vous êtes sur un
réseau social où il y a des petites
vidéos vous économisez de l'énergie donc
c'est la somme de tout ça aussi qui
contribue
à faire
à faire des économies d'énergie moi je
vous l'indique je travaille avec la
french tech corporate community qui est
en gros là aussi un terme un peu
précieux pour
comment dire
réunion enfin qui réunit les directeurs
des services informatiques et
technologiques de la plupart des grandes
entreprises pour qu'ils écrivent
ensemble comment en tant que spécialiste
du sujet
on déploie dans les grandes entreprises
des habitudes de sobriété numérique et
donc ça va de l'utilisation de cet objet
que nous avons tous ou de l'ordinateur à
la manière dont les serveurs sont conçus
dans les nouvelles applications sont
faites dans le recettage de batch
informatique sont conçus etc donc on va
de choses très pratiques et du quotidien
pour tout le monde à des choses plus
techniques pour les spécialistes des
systèmes d'information mais là aussi ça
contribuera de notre sobriété et c'est
un des livrables j'espère attendu pour
notre plan sobriété de juillet
retour d'expérience du sprint et des
sociologues
on a je pense un besoin de documenter et
de s'appuyer sur des travaux académiques
en matière de sobriété on a quelques
[Musique]
on a quelques comment dire association
personnalité qui s'intéresse au sujet
mais on n'a pas encore un corpus très
établi sur ces sur ces sujets là me
semble-t-il
on a un corpus philosophique si vous
reprenez à la philosophie grecque la
question de la sobriété l'insuffisance
etc vous avez beaucoup de choses qui ont
été écrites quand même
dans l'Antiquité et qui n'ont pas pris
une ride je vous y renvoie bien
volontiers
mais c'est vrai que comment on passe je
dirais d'une approche philo
philosophique à sociologiquement comment
on accompagne on rend désirable
une consommation qui est plus durable
comment on met de la valeur dans chaque
élément consommé plutôt que de
privilégier la quantité donc comment
privilégier la qualité à la quantité
comment on a des avant-gardistes qui
prennent position et qui donnent envie à
d'autres de les suivre tous ces éléments
là sont encore
peu je crois explorer et en particulier
il y a un sujet que moi j'ai posé aux
grandes écoles de commerce c'est c'est
quoi le marketing et la publicité
et je pense que ça fait partie aussi du
sujet donc là on est dans
mais pour l'OPEX voilà
moi je suis éblouie par les grandes
écoles qui prennent leur responsabilités
et veulent aller dans la transition
écologique énergétique ok qu'est-ce que
vous enseignez aux élèves en matière
de marketing et en matière de publicité
Gérard le seul je vais prendre la parole
merci président madame la ministre merci
et je vais revenir sur les envolés
philosophiques que vous nous invitez à
faire mais on aura l'occasion au sein de
paix je n'en doute pas dans rediscuter
mais à l'automne la première ministre
déclarait la sobriété et le rationnement
sont de puissance outils de justice
sociale alors certains voient beaucoup
d'ailleurs à l'époque on en doutait et
en tout encore et je reviendrai pas sur
ce que la science politique par ailleurs
décrit comme un potentiel conflit de
cadrage si on laisse s'installer l'idée
que une définition un peu au rabais de
ce que peut-être la sobriété
c'est-à-dire uniquement les petits
gestes mais comment assurer la
conciliation de la sobriété telle que
vous venez de la rappeler avec la
nécessaire équité et justice sociale je
pense notamment à la mise en place des
ETFs par exemple qui touchent de manière
très différenciée nos concitoyens et
qu'il est tous dans leur mobilité quot
vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure mais
j'aimerais bien vous vous entendre un
peu plus sur le sujet de mon point de
vue les incitations à la sobriété
énergétique ne peuvent être crédibles et
avoir une chance d'être suivie par nos
concitoyens que si elles font partie
d'un plan sérieux d'une grande ampleur
de réduction des consommations d'énergie
et donc comment peut-on inciter chacun à
faire des efforts sans vouloir par
exemple
prendre qu'un deuxième exemple réguler
les jets privés si des jets privés
étaient maintenus au sol s'il est
publicités pour l'avion ou pour les
voitures étaient retirées de l'espace
public si la vitesse sur autoroute était
réduite si les publicités pour les gros
SUV par exemple étaient interdites ou le
malus poids intégrer dans la définition
des critères on ne prend que ces
quelques exemples cela alors aurait un
vrai sens de demander aux citoyens de
faire leur part et l'action publique par
ailleurs gagnerait en totale cohérence
alors quid des exonérations fisc qui par
ailleurs coûte cher à la collectivité
nationale en termes budgétaire et en
termes de consommation énergétique
3,3 milliards d'euros manquants du fait
de l'exonération totale du kérosène
aérien sur les vols domestiques 3 à 500
millions d'euros pour les transporteurs
routiers voilà il y a un problème de
cohérence du discours et des actions et
des décisions qui sont prises par la
collectivité nationale et notamment par
l'État et puis pour revenir à la
question qui a été posée et qui vous a
été aussi reposé même si vous avez donné
bien évidemment des éléments de réponse
sur l'exemplarité de l'État et vous avez
eu raison de le dire d'emblée dans le
plan que vous nous avez présenté on le
sait sur la gestion thermique des
bâtiments c'est pas top
et encore moins sur les installations
d'énergie renouvelables et donc il faut
vraiment que l'État que la puissance
publique donne des signes forts
d'implication dans cette transition
énergétique et d'être dans cette
sobriété énergétique je vous remercie de
vos réponses madame la ministre
alors sur le dernier point je crois que
je suis totalement d'accord avec vous
c'est à dire l'exemplarité de l'État
c'est effectivement levier le plus
facile et le plus accessible
et d'ailleurs on le met en oeuvre c'est
à dire que l'État a strictement respecté
la température de consigne a accéléré
son équipement en gestion technique des
bâtiments est en train d'explorer un
certain nombre d'installations d'énergie
renouvelables l'Élysée et rocklore les
premiers puisque nous regardons le
potentiel en géothermie
pour mais tout ça prend du temps et
c'est des travaux et ça relève plutôt
d'ailleurs de l'efficacité énergétique
d'un côté de l'utilisation des énergies
renouvelables de l'autre mais je partage
l'idée que pour faire bouger
les Français il faut commencer par les
gros acteurs et il faut commencer par
l'État combien de réflexion un peu
piquantes j'ai eu sur les réseaux
sociaux au moment où on a lancé le plan
sobriété en disant oui mais de toute
façon c'est bien que dans les ministères
il fera 23 degrés etc je peux vous
assurer qu'on était plutôt en dessous de
19 et mes équipes souris parce que tous
les matins j'avais un thermomètre dans
mon bureau quand ça dépassé 19 c'était
rappel à l'ordre généralisé donc les
choses étaient très claires
voilà ils peuvent
en témoigner
sur sur la question ensuite du plan
précisément le plan sobriété c'est bien
gardé d'être une somme des cogestes le
plan sobriété c'est d'abord la
mobilisation des grandes entreprises des
grandes collectivités locales et des
grandes administrations avec un
reporting avec des chiffres associés
secteur par secteur le sport est capable
de vous dire combien ils ont gagné en
éclairage en consommation d'éclairage à
au début et à la fin des compétitions et
ils ont partagé un certain nombre de
bonnes pratiques entre eux aujourd'hui
dans la Ligue 1 je crois que vous avez
18 ou 20 clubs qui respectent ces
consignes de d'éclairage sur les grandes
comp tout le monde n'a pas encore résolu
le problème de transport des des joueurs
puisqu'on a effrayé à plusieurs fois la
chronique mais vous avez comme toujours
d'ailleurs dans ces sujets à une somme
d'enjeu à regarder y compris les enjeux
de sécurité etc donc bon mais
effectivement ce qui apparaissait comme
ridicule et anecdotique il y a quelques
années ne vient aujourd'hui tout à fait
sérieux et central et aujourd'hui
regardez comme un des éléments
de notoriété des clubs et nous y
travaillons avec Amélie ou desa Castéra
et je pourrais multiplier les exemples
dans la culture le fait de travailler à
ce que des grands festivals arrêtent
d'utiliser des générateurs électriques
au fioul mais utilise enedis pour enfin
ça a l'air de rien mais c'est vrai que
ça fait pas très sérieux d'avoir des
grands spectacles avec des générateurs
of fuel derrière bon voilà donc c'est
c'est des choses très précises et
portées par des les grands les grands
acteurs
sur le sujet de de l'équité sociale je
le partage aussi et d'ailleurs vous
observerez qu'un certain nombre de
mesures sont prises je l'ai indiqué feat
for fifty-five désormais ne laisse plus
de côté le secteur de l'aviation et le
secteur du transport maritime ils
paieront leur écho est-ce qu'il payeront
à ses décos c'est un point qui peut être
disputé mais aujourd'hui il n'échappe
pas y compris dans le cadre d'un
discours qui dit attention les traités
internationaux non au niveau européen
tous ces secteurs là
payent d'une manière d'une autre un prix
de la tonne carbone et nous sommes en
train de monter les exigences d'une
année sur l'autre avec je le rappelle
parce que je trouve que cela est souvent
rapidement balayé
de la main le texte fit for fifty-five
c'est 3500 pages de législation
3500 pages c'est le texte le plus
ambitieux et le plus exigeant au monde
en matière de transition énergétique et
climatique au monde c'est tellement
exigeant d'ailleurs que beaucoup de gens
nous disent ça va être très difficile
sur le terrain ça va poser des problèmes
sociaux ça va me poser des problèmes
d'acceptabilité etc
aussi plutôt sous ce registre là que je
le regarde aujourd'hui c'est comment on
le déploie en prenant en compte le fait
que nous ne sommes pas tous au même
endroit en termes de consommation
d'énergie de capacité à sortir des
consommations d'énergie fossiles le
malus poids dans les critères de soutien
public ils existent
on peut dire c'est pas assez on doit en
faire plus etc mais ils existent en
réalité
les les exonérations fiscales sur le
transport routier c'est un sujet qui
revient je pense depuis 4 ans maintenant
en tout cas moi en tant que mini je l'ai
toujours connu à chaque PLF qui donne
lieu à des discussions assez assez
toniques entre effectivement les deux
éléments que nous devons porter d'un
côté c'est à dire un faire en sorte
qu'il n'y ait plus de niche fiscale
fossiles et de l'autre côté la réalité
de l'impact de du fait de retirer
signifie fiscales sur les transporteurs
je pense pas que les transporteurs
soient les personnes les plus comment
dire les plus riches
celles qui profite le plus de la
situation etc elle contribuer le son à
maillon d'approvisionnement de
logistique dans notre pays assez
indispensable et donc qu'est-ce que on
est capable de faire qu'est-ce qu'on
n'est pas capable de faire faire à
quelle vitesse on peut les accompagner
pour
changer et diminuer leur consommation de
carburant sachant qu'en plus nous
n'avons pas aujourd'hui une offre
pléthorique de transport
décarbonés pour faire du transport
routier c'est une vraie question c'est
une vraie question et je pense que c'est
notre responsabilité effectivement de
d'aborder cette question en
ayant systématiquement la question de
c'est quoi l'alternative
si les transporteurs doivent sortir du
carbone c'est quoi leur alternative et
comment on accompagne leur alternative
nous aujourd'hui nous subventionnons
l'émergence de poids lourds qui soient
décarbonés soit hydrogène soit
électrique et nous mettons de l'argent
sur la table dessus
et nous essayons d'accompagner la
transition de ces transporteurs parce
que le prix des poids lourds en question
et deux fois trois fois plus cher que
l'option qu'ils auraient avec du
carburant
donc c'est ces réalités là je pense
qu'il faut qu'il faut vraiment adresser
et prendre garde aussi à
au fond et une petite tentation qu'on
peut avoir collectivement de prendre une
mesure forte
et puisqu'on faisait des
propos philosophiques
on a les mains propres on a interdit
ceci cela mais en fait on n'a pas de
main parce que
ceci ou cela se recrée ailleurs sur le
territoire planétaire et au fond on a
exporté
la pollution ce qui est
terriblement hypocrite
mais aussi terriblement destructeur de
notre tissu économique et terriblement
des faveurs des personnes les plus
précaires je le dis en connaissance de
cause
je suis sur le territoire du bassin
minier on a perdu des milliers d'emplois
des dizaines de milliers d'emplois avec
l'industrialisation d'abord la fermeture
des mines mais ensuite avec les
restructurations successives d'un
certain nombre de secteurs industriels
lourds et automobile et aujourd'hui
c'est stigmatelas on les mesure
clairement sur le territoire en termes
de proportion de personnes qui sont RSA
en termes de perspective pour les jeunes
en termes de
d'abstentionnisme en termes politiques
si parce que lorsque notre pays est
capable de fabriquer des SUV la question
ce qui se pose c'est est-ce qu'on ferme
les usines qui fabrique des SUV qui
seront fabriqués de l'autre côté de la
frontière on a les mains propres
on sort de la compétition on sort des
milliers d'emplois on sort des milliers
d'emplois et c'est pas vous et moi c'est
des gens qui ont un bac pro
électrotechniciens ou usinage ou etc
et pour retrouver bonne nouvelle moi mon
territoire il est encore à deux chiffres
en termes de chômage aujourd'hui
la question de la question du prix alors
j'essaie de retrouver ce que j'avais
marqué en tout cas vous avez évoqué
la question du numérique alors moi ça
j'aimerais bien vous demander comment
vous allez travailler là-dessus va-t-il
avoir des études parce qu'on est tout et
n'importe quoi et on lit souvent que le
numérique
finalement consomme énormément de choses
énormément d'électricité qui ne sont
toujours
connectés que ce soit les téléphones les
ordinateurs ou tout ce qu'on fait donc
est-ce que vous avez prévu de lancer une
une étude là-dessus la deuxième question
que vous avez parlé de la communication
en parlant de l'impact sur la
biodiversité l'impact sur la santé mais
mais je pense aussi aussi qu'il faut
continuer à parler de coups
contrairement à vous je crois pas que
tout le monde se soit rendu compte tenu
de la communication qu'il y avait des
tarifs qui étaient réglementés et que ça
allait pas qu'ils étaient peu impactés
mais dans les aspects positifs le coude
ne doit être aussi un élément important
et pas simplement sur les aspects
énergétiques enfin sur les aspects
biodiversité énergétique et dernière
élément l'excès en karité de l'État
vous êtes vous êtes très optimiste mais
moi dans les écoles le 19 degré il passe
pas
quand les élèves y compris les
enseignants et quand il fait un peu
froid ils sont à 19 degrés les parents
ils apprécient peu et des enseignants
aussi d'avoir froid donc est-ce que le
19 degré enfin on n'est pas de ou en
maternelle
oui mais
c'est je dirais il y a des endroits dans
lesquels
c'est compliqué voilà c'était les seules
remarques
je vais être très rapide merci monsieur
le Président merci Madame la Ministre
permets-moi un pas de côté et de vous
dire que le petit-fils de paysan
corrézien que je suis ravi de voir que
mon atavisme paysan qui a fait de la
sobriété un mode de vie millénaire est
importé à la ville voilà voilà pour une
fois que la Haute Corrèze est en avance
sur son temps j'en suis extrêmement
extrêmement satisfait sur sur
l'Antiquité oui il y a plein de choses à
apprendre je rappelle comme ça que
l'empereur Tibère avait mis à mort un
artisan varié qui lui avait proposé du
verre incassable parce que ça pouvait
prendre du travail aux autres ouvriers
donc il y a une relation dans
l'Antiquité oui tout à fait c'est ce que
plineur raconte donc il a raison
donc il y a un rapport au progrès à la
technologie qui est très différent de
celui d'aujourd'hui
alors pourquoi ces deux exemples je
pense comme notre collègue Jean-Luc Fuji
qu'on a besoin des sciences qu'on a
besoin de la connaissance et qu'on a
besoin des des sciences humaines et vous
nous avez dit que vous pouvez solliciter
des compétences individuelles mais
est-ce que il sera pas de bonne
politique que votre ministère passe des
programmes des contrats d'objectifs avec
les grands opérateurs de la recherche
est-ce que vous pourriez pas aller voir
le CNRS pour lui dire monsieur CNRS s'il
vous plaît ou madame
est-ce que vous pourriez mobiliser vos
chercheurs vos compétences sont tel ou
tel domaine où on a besoin de votre
expertise je crois qu'on a besoin
aujourd'hui d'une programmation de de la
recherche et peut-être que votre
ministère est pourra être en point dans
ce domaine je m'arrête
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il faut
garder les appels à projets dans le
financement de la recherche
merci beaucoup alors sur le numérique
les données qu'on a on s'est 2% de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre une
projection de multiplication par 3 d'ici
2050 et 10% dans le consommation
d'électricité avec comme principal
source
de consommation les outils donc pas
forcément les usages mais la production
des outils ce qui vraiment est un très
fort appel aux reconditionnement à la
durabilité de ces outils à tout le
travail qui a commencé à être fait pour
lutter contre l'obsolescence programmée
dans certains nombre de textes et que
met en oeuvre la DGCCRF mais il faut
probablement aller aller plus loin se
poser la question aussi de quelle mesure
pour inciter à
réparer à versus changer
ensuite il y a un programme au niveau du
numérique puisqu'on l'avait lancé avec
alors City je pense elle est Cédric non
je l'avais fait d'abord avec le
ministère de la transition écologique
comme moi j'étais du côté de Bercy qui
était une évaluation
de la de notre empreinte numérique enfin
de notre empreinte carbone pour le
numérique et un plan pour faire en sorte
que cette empreinte numérique reste
stable poste 2025 c'est-à-dire on a une
croissance c'était en 2019 2019 je crois
donc on avait une croissance jusqu'en
2025 et ensuite on revenait au niveau de
2019 par c'était dans le secteur des
télécoms plus précisément par des
opérations successives notamment vous
savez que le réseau cuivre la 2G et la
3G et la 4G sont moins efficaces que la
5G et donc en utilisant le levier des
technologies on avait vocation à
absorber l'augmentation des usages de de
la data derrière ça il y a aussi tout le
travail qui est fait et que j'ai
mentionné
déco conception des applications
numériques de manière par exemple je
vous donne un exemple on est peut-être
pas obligé de rafraîchir toutes les deux
heures certaines applications en usage
en entreprise alors qu'on peut le faire
tous les jours on peut le faire toutes
les semaines enfin c'est des choses
comme ça alors c'est un peu technique
mais ça a des vrais impacts en matière
de consommation énergétique et ce qui
est clair c'est que
Cédric
Jean-Noël Barrault ont effectivement
repris le flambeau avec
des objets des objectifs de
décarbonation de la filière numérique et
de suivi avec des plans d'action qui
sont assez précis aujourd'hui je vous
invite probablement à les peut-être les
auditionner puisqu'ils ont moi j'ai
lâché l'affaire il y a trois ans mais
puisque c'est Cédric succédé sur la
partie Télécom mais je pense que enfin
je pense pas je sais que ça continue sur
sur la question de l'effet prix je suis
complètement d'accord l'effet prix est
par construction un élément très
classique pour contenir notre
consommation et donc il faut l'utiliser
c'est ce que je disais revoir les niches
fiscales marrons c'est une façon
d'aller vers moins de consommation
d'énergie il se posait la question de la
facturation enfin du tarif règle pardon
de du bouclier ou du prix du gaz versus
celui de l'électricité sachant que notre
électricité des carbonée à 90% pas le
gaz c'est une très bonne question la
TICE versus la CGN c'est une très bonne
question c'est des questions sur
lesquelles d'ailleurs on vous fera
probablement des propositions sur la
question du 19 degré je veux le préciser
le 19 degrés et il s'impose dans les
bureaux il est dans la loi c'est pas moi
qui l'ai mis en 1978 j'avais 4 ans donc
je pouvais passer vire
les 19 degrés c'est une température qui
est assez communément partagée que ce
soit par
l'expertise médicale puisque vous savez
qu'on vous demande même d'être en
dessous de 19 degrés dans les chambres
notamment pour les enfants
mais qui a été en fait la vérité assez
commune de tous les européens qui ont
mis en place des plans sobriété alors de
court terme de passage de l'hiver en
revanche on avait bien précisé je vais
vous rassurer que sur les crèches les
maternelles et les EHPAD on augmentait
la température
un des problèmes qu'on a c'est un
chauffage qui est fixé à 19 degrés dans
une passoire thermique
parce que là c'est pas 19 degrés là
c'est 15 degrés et ça c'est le vrai
sujet et c'est là où il faut combiner
aussi un vrai pilotage de du bâtiment et
une réponse au Passeport thermique et
dans pas mal d'écoles et c'est l'enjeu
aussi du plan école qui a lancé
Christophe Béchu de financement avec du
tiers financement et de rénovation
thermique on a effectivement un intérêt
à rénover thermiquement ces bâtiments
parce qu'on a des retombées très rapides
c'est-à-dire un en baisse nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre deux on baisse
nos consommations d'énergie trois les
enfants et les professeurs travaillent
dans des conditions de travail agréables
d'ailleurs l'été comme l'hiver parce que
l'été avec de la canicule à 35 degrés
c'est pas tellement mieux que l'hiver
quand il fait 15 degrés dans les cases
donc je rejoins complètement ce que vous
dites et nous notre enjeu c'est de
déployer rapidement ce plan
pardon alors Monsieur
la Corrèze
très joli département mais ce que vous
dites en creux est très juste c'est à
dire que on s'est satisfait d'un certain
nombre de conditions de cadres de vie
sans sont forcément remonter au
Moyen-Âge qui ne faisait pas grief et
qui est manifestement était très
supportable je pense en terme de
température etc
non là vous mettez le point sur un sujet
que auquel on n'a pas réfléchi on va le
lire très simplement avoir des contrats
d'objectifs avec des grands opérateurs
de la recherche ça pourrait être un des
une des recommandations du groupe
sobriété qui travaille sur la loi de
programmation énergique climat et en
tout cas moi je prends le point et j'en
parle à ma collègue Sylvie Retailleau je
doute que elle n'est pas une
appréciation bienveillante de ce type
d'approche
bien je laisse la parole à Gérard
Longuet pour conclure sur cette audition
avec Madame le Ministre pardonnez-moi
une extrême brièveté car nous sommes
sollicités par la séance de questions
d'actualité je voudrais un vous
remercier d'être venu au Sénat nous
parler de la sobriété qui est une vertu
exemplaire dont l'État prend en charge
la diffusion ce qui risque d'aboutir à
des paradoxes ou à des situations
cocasses quand il est vrai que dans sa
complexité l'État n'est pas le plus
exemplaire pour parler de sobriété et si
l'entre dans le détail il risque de
confiner au ridicule il se trouve que en
soit vous êtes né en 74 un rapide calcul
moi j'étais jeune sous-préfet en 74 et
le ministère intérieur nous avait envoyé
une belle circulaire après le deuxième
choc pétrolier pour l'extinction des
vitrines de commerce à 10h du soir c'est
évidemment été l'émotion dans toute la
France et appliquée d'une façon très
inégale et en fait avec une obsolescence
programmée de de cette mesure très très
rapidement je crois qu'il faut pas que
l'État rentre trop dans le détail en
revanche vous êtes ici à l'Office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques technologiques et il faut
se poser la question de savoir si la
consommation si le patrimoine de CO2 que
les Français peuvent mobiliser pour leur
vie quotidienne ne doit pas pouvoir
faire l'objet non pas d'un suivi
centralisé par Big Brother mais d'une
évaluation par chacun d'entre nous pour
savoir où nous en sommes et savoir quel
est le geste qui nous paraît le plus
intelligent à cet égard je partage la
vie de notre collègue député Sarah tout
et de Madame progressia l'effet prix
quand même a été dissuasif et je veux je
tiens à vous envoyer tout à l'heure mais
mes factures de chauffage au gaz pour
vous montrer que ça quand même doublé
dans la plupart des cas j'ai du mal à
comprendre l'effet du bouclier mais
c'est pas grave je dois mal gérer mon
budget
c'est beaucoup plus cher et à ce moment
là on fait attention et l'effet prix est
le premier le premier levier en revanche
je crois que globalement
que chacun est l'idée de son patrimoine
de CO2 et en particulier pour répondre
au jet privé la plupart des jets privés
sont utilisés par des entreprises pour
des besoins
professionnels qu'une entreprise est un
patrimoine de CO2 qu'il doit qu'il
puisse qu'ils puissent utiliser et qu'il
est à la fois des économies d'un côté et
des dépenses de l'autre et qu'il affecte
lui-même ses économies au bénéfice de
telles dépenses je crois qu'on serait
dans une logique de responsabilité et en
pleine en plafonnant ces émissions et je
crois que l'Office devrait pouvoir
travailler sur les tous les tous les
systèmes de contrôle de mesures qui
permettent d'avoir à tout moment cette
situation par rapport à ce bien qui est
indispensable à la vie mais dans l'excès
peut-être nuisible je prends
l'exemple très simple des compteurs
Linky pour l'électricité comme pour le
gaz c'est une véritable révolution
poursuivre sa consommation et c'est
puisque nous avons des choix
technologiques à évaluer en tant que
OPEX c'est plutôt dans ce domaine là
j'ajoute que une bonne maîtrise de
grands choix scientifique quand on passe
de 450 térawh à 300 tt dans le
patrimoine français de l'énergie
électrique
toutes nos petites économies sont
balayées par une seule décision qui
certainement pertinente légitime mais on
voit bien que les systèmes centralisés
s'ils ne sont pas maîtrisés et s'ils
peuvent déraper
découragent les gestes individuels dont
l'addition totale représente en général
une part très minoritaire des grands
acteurs voilà la décarbonation de des
process industriels par exemple des
carbonation achevée complète de
l'énergie est un devoir absolu et
c'est plutôt le rôle de l'office de voir
quel est le couronnement de tel ou telle
mesure après que nous soyons aussi vite
c'est un vœu général et quant à la
sobriété je la partage puisque j'ai même
renoncé au vin en mes journées
et pour ça remplace le chauffage oui
enfin le bilan carbone du vin
écoutez merci Madame la Ministre plus
technique moins morale et plus technique
en tout cas s'il y a un point sur lequel
nous n'avons pas fait preuve de ce
briété c'est bien sur la réflexion nous
avons menée aujourd'hui sur ce sujet
merci Madame la Ministre encore à vous
et on peut lever la séance et notamment
pour nos amis pour aller